anyway we're going to move on with with
Eddie's brilliant circle in the
background I am going to show you are
three examples I've definitely thought
areas to do with the inverse trig
functions and a few tips of tricks that
you need to evaluate them apart from
just the normal ways that you were doing
things okay so here's what I'm gonna
purchase when it comes to inverse trig
functions for K all of the inverse trig
functions sine inverse causing us tan
inverse you want to consider their areas
with regard to two things two things you
need to watch out for the first thing is
simply okay just like the original trig
functions there's an enormous amount of
distributing you need to take advantage
of when you're doing your definite
integral so look at some easy examples
and some trickier ones okay the other
thing you want to keep in mind is how
similar they are to the original trig
functions if all you are working at is
an area if that's all you're interested
in okay then it doesn't matter which
functions you consider so long as you
end up with the right number at the end
okay so I start with a very simple
example let's try our soft side of us
okay don't forget you ought to have
vertical tangents at your end point so
you should be slicing across about 45
degrees okay so if I wanted an area that
correspond to this what's that look like
if I'm ending it one that looks like
it's about a half from negative half to
a half of sine inverse okay so let's
form the integral the integral for this
would be from negative half to a half of
sorry that's right okay so what's the
answer it's zero isn't it on what
grounds would you simply say it's zero
okay so specifically I mean symmetry is
the idea right but there aren't many
many clients a cemetery right so you
need to specify which one's going on so
I would say equals zero as sine inverse
is our what kind of function it's an odd
function good okay because your
boundaries are on you know opposite of
each other that's fine now let's change
up the question a little bit suppose I
don't want just the actual just the
straight definite integral suppose I
really do want the area that's shaded
okay we're going to use symmetry again
but we're going to use it in a slightly
different way how can I go about this
okay so the first thing I could say is
the area area not just in integral okay
is going to be double now what's the
integral I should fall I could do it
either way could not but you know you
might as well go for words rather than
backwards and had positive rather than
negatives okay so the integral of this
sine inverse okay now we are used to
evaluating you tools right but if you
don't know integration by parts you kind
of stuck at this point right which is
where we get to our next point here then
I want to make some kind of comparison
with the original trig functions which
actually even though maybe you feel kind
of fancy because you do know what the
young what the preview function of this
is it is actually much easier this is an
extension one student to consider this
in comparison to well new set of axes
let's draw ourselves sine X ok sorry I'm
going to destroy your circles on okay
why don't worry you can draw another one
now let's draw the corresponding part of
sine X ok so what would that look like
so just like I had my vertical tangents
they got my horizontal ones here sorry
I'm a little bit off now where's the
area I want how does this and really I'm
just interested in on make it a bit more
solid I'm really just interested in that
area by the time where is that on this
diagram if this is sine X well this is
these are expanders aren't there right
going from an inverse back to the
original function I want y dome and that
makes sense because ones are there it's
the amplitude isn't it so there's one
there's our half ok now the area over
there is done to the x axis so the area
of over here ought to be bounded to the
glue ok so this is the area I'm after ok
so good now if I want to work out this
area the simplest way to consider it is
just to remember that when i integrate I
don't get area above the curve I get
area below the curve right so let's call
this area in here let's give it a day I
don't know something like I don't want
to call it capital a turkey that's over
there let's call it was called be ok
secondary area B what's its area what
kind of integral would I form well i'm
going i'm back in X's down I know so
it's from zero to whatever this value
ought to be now I've chosen half for a
reason because it will give you a nice
simple one it should be pile six good
okay and you can almost see that if
you've drawn that reasonably you know
platitudes over here so your guess is a
kind of bounded right so I've got my
integral from 0 to PI on 6 of sine X ok
let's quickly work it out what is it
you're going to have a primitive of
negative cause
from nought to PI on six okay so
negative cause I love sex what's that
that's negative root 3 on 2 isn't it yes
I've got a double negative happening so
watch out I'd usually subtract you but I
should actually have a plus what's cause
of 0 1 okay there you go so that's area
be okay I want this area though the one
that I've shaded over here so how am I
going to get that area out of this one
yeah I'll need to know what that whole
rectangle is why know where is it I want
to know what this whole shape is and
then i can subtract the B UK with that
so now I'm going to say a is equal to if
half pint and pound 6 wide so let's
apply on 12 and i'm going to subtract
this area if i subtract it is attractive
sorry I'm it's fine as well Big Pine six
times are hard yeah if i subtract it on
my sides flu so this is what i get is
that okay alright cool so I've worked
out one piece now I can come back over
to my original question of course I
don't want one I want two of them yes so
the real area that I'm after this whole
lot is going to be what by on 6 plus
root 3 minus two is that ok it's ok
there you go so there's two things to
consider both of them are areas but they
use the symmetry in different ways